it's our last episode before christmas
the yuletide season happy holidays
i know sony you celebrate uh armenian
christmas which is later right i
celebrate both but to give myself more
time to get gifts i say i celebrate
armenian christmas every year when
christmas comes and this is i've known
sona a long time
christmas comes and i give her her gift
and it's always you know as you can
imagine i'm almost like surprised and
she's like oh my god and i go and here
are the keys and um
[Laughter]
1968. no i get her a nice uh you always
you're very generous i give you a nice
gift yeah and then i'm kind of there's
part of me that's waiting we're like oh
what am i going to get from sona and
it's nothing i don't get any christmas
gift but then
it's because i forget that sona is very
happy to get a christmas gift
but what she really likes to do
then is only give gifts on armenian
christmas which is a couple of weeks
later right january 6th yes it's the
orthodox christmas it's the orthodox
christmas and and to give a shout out uh
the uh armenians or the original it's
the oldest sect of christianity isn't
the uh first country to accept
christianity as the national religion
they did it in 301 the greeks will say
they did it but they didn't the greeks
say a lot of [ __ ] yeah but can we all
agree on the greeks
don't get me started on the greeks but
if that's the one
distinguishing characteristic of our
podcast is man there's a lot of greek
hate going around
on conan's podcast conan o'brien needs a
friend no greeky but no greeks
yeah conan o'brien has banned zach
galifianakis
from his podcast as he's an upcoming
guest
hey zach you're on my [ __ ] list you and
all those other greeks aristotle uh
aristotle's on your [ __ ] oh yeah man
when i see that guy coming he can't
leave him on this podcast he can i don't
want to listen to his sort of weird
pseudo-wisdom um
holidays are a little loaded for me uh i
want to preface this by saying i love my
wife uh very much and whenever someone
says that whenever someone in
entertainment says that
a lot you know that their marriage is in
trouble um no my wife liza is is
terrific but i'm realizing that we have
very different uh philosophies about
christmas decorations okay i'm realizing
that my wife is very tasteful yes she
comes from a more wasp uh waspish
culture okay um and they're very
tasteful people and good people and um
of course i come from uh from horrible
irish pirates and
i'm realizing that whenever christmas
comes around i'm always trying to put up
my wife always just wants there to be
kind of white lights just pure white
lights
and and not too many of them but just an
appropriate amount very elegant elegant
and simple and i realize that i'm always
um whenever she's doing that i'm always
in the corner trying to order uh a
plastic santa on a toilet that spins
that goes on your front yard i have that
in me i like multi-colored lights at
christmas and i know that i am a
full-grown adult
and
there's no excuse for it but i like
multi-colored lights i don't think you
need to explain am i for that i do too
no no my wife says that's cool on the
tree but i swear to god if i was let
free
um there would be uh you know
angels and santas and snowmen
you just rock [ __ ] around
yeah just [ __ ] and tinsel uh all over
the place um i can't help it i have and
i realized that uh when i was a kid
my brother neal really read that led the
charge he got uh
he got from my grandparents
he got like this light up santa claus
that was really like over the top um
tacky and a light up snowman and he hung
them without my parents permission he
hung them out the front door
out of his window which is the side of
this that's facing the street and um
just he put up as much of that stuff as
possible and this santa looked like a
drunk it looked like a big fat drunk man
it was lit and it was one of those ones
that was made in like the late 40s or
early 50s yeah and he had like a he was
a leering drunk santa and then a big
frosty the snowman and my brother neil
would just with no um sense of decorum
would just throw these things out the
window and they would hang there off an
extension cord and my mother of course
was horrified but i think i grew up with
that thinking that's well that's what it
should be yeah um i want all that stuff
and so
i've noticed that whenever i start to
pitch a christmas decoration to my wife
her whole body tenses
i can just see her whole body tense like
she's like the second before an
automobile accident the way someone
tenses up and puts their arms up
and uh and and she knows
anything i say is gonna be a well we'll
let's think about that yeah let's think
about a a leprechaun that's wearing a
santa hat oh no that uh shoots them and
m's out its ass let's just think about
that that sounds good like there's it's
only 44 and they can deliver it tomorrow
oh you can play human centipede with
that
i did order a uh a bunch of human
centipede santas once a couple years ago
and she didn't want it out there no oh
what liza that's unreasonable i know
eliza
come on
why are you harshing my mellow you know
this is my don't yuck my yum this is my
joy
you know you know what your house is
very elegant and sophisticated so it
would be weird if you had like a drunken
leprechaun i know but there's part of me
that that uh you know your true nature
which is
it's not just my dna but it's also how i
was raised and the influence of my
oldest brother neil there's part of me
that just wants to go hog wild yeah and
uh and and be insane it's a time to be
insane could you do your office that way
like couldn't you have a little
allocated room just for your christmas
fun a little conan corner yeah a little
place no i want to impose it on people
on other people you know
i want uh you know i want other people
to be forced to see it you should take
an apartment in the city that's not for
a lover but just to decorate
i love that decoration i love that i'll
be the only celebrity that got a secret
apartment on the side not to meet my
mistress but to just decorate
with tacky christmas crap and then i go
there and i drink overly sweet instant
cocoa
and watch frosty the snowman backwards
in my feety pajamas
and uh and then occasionally walk
outside and and look at my tacky little
uh pier tear yeah
and then uh
never in the neighborhood's like conan
must have a mistress in there
and i'm like huh mistress er yes yes
mistress
uh mistress claws what's that national
enquirer yes mistress in there just so i
i look like less of a loser
cause no one would rent this just to
decorate it with tacky christmas [ __ ]
yeah no no mistress um
mistress in there yes her name's
santina
klaus what
you seem like a bad liar conan um if you
were allowed to do whatever you wanted
would it be like the house and christmas
vacation yeah it would be terrible yeah
no i wouldn't go that far but it would
be bad my wife is right i do think my
wife is right but um as she is in most
things
except in choice of husband
[Music]
she missed it there she could have done
better but uh i i think she's right but
there's this impulse i have which is
oh my god you know i could uh
there's no reason why that piece of
furniture can't have multi-colored
lights wrapped around it i get it though
there's a there's a like
tough tug of war between the elegance
but also christmas is a season of like
childhood joy and kind of yes
and uh and i think it's come to
represent uh you know america's uh
expression of its dominance in the world
um oh and uh capitalism and it's uh
its defeat of other forms of organizing
society okay well anyway my god that's
what did you do to christmas that's what
i think christmas is all about
um you heard it here first
conan o'brien can't stand the greeks